con cưng của TikTok gọi tên BTS
màn comeback của BTS khiến TikTok hóa sân nhà của Army
ưu ái mở chiến dịch riêng từ Avatar
rồi sau nhạc hay comment đều có hiệu ứng
đặc biệt là màn săn lùng sticker
chưa từng có sự trở lại của BTS
lần này đúng nghĩa là một cú đổ bộ toàn diện
sau thời gian dài chờ đợi
màn comeback không chỉ gây bão về âm nhạc
mà còn kéo Theo loạt hiệu ứng phủ kín
TikTok biến nền tảng này thành sân nhà của Army
chỉ cần search từ khóa BTS
màn hình lập tức xuất hiện hiệu ứng 7 thành viên
chạy ngang như một thước phim
đặc biệt khi gõ tên bias
hệ thống còn Hiển thị đúng hình thành viên đó
khiến fan thích thú cực độ
chưa dừng lại ở đó
sau khi search sẽ mở Ra một chuỗi nhiệm vụ Cho fan
từ tham gia đoạn chất trên trang TikTok của BTS
tìm kiếm từ khóa
lưu SV
y M vào app âm nhạc Cho đến đăng bài kèm hashtag chủ đề
hoàn thành các bước là được nhận mũ thủy thủ
gắn Avatar chuẩn Army
còn unlock chọn bộ sticker Theo album
ngay cả phần bình luận cũng được nâng cấp
khi gõ BTS
sẽ xuất hiện animation bơi lội Theo vibe CA khúc chủ đề SV
y M câu hoành tráng lần này còn được netizen đặt lên bản
cân với utopia loạt
phim từng được TikTok ưu ái dành hiệu ứng riêng
tuy nhiên nếu utopia chỉ dừng lại ở mức filter
và Chen search từ khóa LAN truyền
thì BTS lại được đầu tư hẳn một hệ thống tương tác
không chỉ dừng lại ở âm nhạc
BTS đang biến màn
comeback thành một event mạng xã hội đúng nghĩa
nơi fan không chỉ nghe
mà còn được tham gia và tương tác trực tiếp